notre invité ce matin c'est le ministre
de l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
bonjour julien de normandie pour merci
beaucoup d'être avec simple pendant un
peu plus de vingt minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
julien lécuyer de la voix du nord
bonjour julien bonjour yann bonjour
monsieur munissant joueurs et on
commence évidemment par l'inquiétude
dans les vignobles français je viens de
normandie dû aux conditions climatiques
et le gel qui touche plusieurs
départements on a vu un ces images de
viticulteurs allumé des feux allumé des
bougies pour tenter de réchauffer leurs
vignes est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
ce matin s'il ya eu des dégâts dans les
vignes françaises
il ya eu des dégâts dans les vignes mais
pas que dans le secteur de
l'arboriculture dans le secteur des
grandes cultures également en fait on a
eu un épisode climatique qui a été en
tout point exceptionnel c'est à dire
qu'on a d'abord eu de très fortes
températures qui a conduit les plantes à
développer et à commencer à fleurir et
ensuite on a eu une chute très brutal et
très forte des températures ce qui en
agronomie et le pire des scénarii c'est
à nouveau passer d'un d'un moment très
chaud avec une très forte éclosion à un
moment très froid qui vient tuer les
fleurs et les végétaux et donc oui et
des dégâts il ya des dégâts qui sont
importants dégâts qu'on pourra mesurer
de manière précise que dans les
prochains jours une fois que cette
période de gel est passé les gars dans
certains départements en particulier
alors on la masse de froid a été plus
importante que celle qu'on imaginait au
départ qui fait qu' elle s'est en plus
déplacée au fur et à mesure des 48
dernières heures et donc malheureusement
l'étendue géographique des dca
probablement sera assez étendue
donc c'était évidemment un sujet pour
lequel d'abord moi je voudrais saluer
l'incroyable mobilisation de nos
viticulteurs arboriculteurs de nos
agriculteurs on a vu des images qui sont
absolument incroyable avec véritablement
une bataille contre ce froid qui a été
opérée vraiment une solidarité
au sein de la profession mais je dirais
même une solidarité républicaine
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble de ces acteurs
qui vivent un moment très difficile
et puis évidemment au moment où ce type
izod de froid sera passé au moment où
cette bataille sera fini d'être livrés
nous allons nous réunir avec l'ensemble
des filières pour évaluer précisément
les dégâts voir comment on peut apporter
des soutiens comment on peut accompagner
les filières qui vont être remises en
inspirera aussi alors on comprend que ce
n'est pas encore l'heure du bilan
mais mais ce qui est ce que vous pouvez
rassurer les agriculteurs sur le fait
que les il y aura un travail avec les
assurances pour être sûr que tout sera
couvert et que vous pourrez apporter des
aides aussi pour compenser les pertes
alors oui évidemment beaucoup de
personnes auront un rôle majeur à jouer
dans les cultures qu'on dit assurables
je pense par exemple aux vignes je pense
par exemple à la grande culture
il va nous falloir mobiliser très
fortement les assureurs avec qui
d'ailleurs je serai en contact
prochainement pour pouvoir justement mme
assuré de leur mobilisation aux côtés
des agriculteurs
ensuite il yad'autres de cette
mobilisation des assureurs non je n'en
doute pas mais je pense que c'est très
important et c'est mon rôle de faire en
sorte que une pression de dingue tubes
soient mises pour à cette crise de froid
ne soit pas additionner une inertie
assurantiel et je crois que personne ne
l'accepterai mais ayant dit cela
je m'appuierai évidemment sur ses
assureurs pour que pour qu'il soit à
leurs côtés et aux côtés des
agriculteurs et puis il ya d'autres
cultures qui elles ne sont pas assurées
par les assureurs et relèvent d'autres
régimes notamment parfois des régimes de
calamité agricole et tout cela
évidemment nous l'étudierons avec des
professionnels
il nous faut quelques jours la nature
étant ce qu'elle est pour mesurer
précisément l'ampleur des dégâts mais
assurément les dégâts vont être forts
qui me servir d'enseignement sur quel
type de culture vignes arboriculture et
certains types de cultures céréalières
qui étaient déjà rentrés en fleurs ou
qui venait juste de pousser rendre en
fleurs je pense au colza venant juste
sortir de terre je pense aux betteraves
par exemple et donc tout cela évidemment
il une mobilisation totale pour
accompagner évaluer et voir quelles
peuvent être les solutions à trouver
mais il c'est vrai que c'est un nouveau
coup dur qui plus est dans un contexte
qui est déjà difficile pour nos
agriculteurs notamment celles et ceux
qui ont vu beaucoup de débouchés se
ferme et du fait du confinement je pense
aux viticulteurs et donc c'est un
nouveau coup dur et cette solidarité
nationale doit s'exprimer
on va parler d'un autre sujet qui
inquiète les agriculteurs c'est la
réforme de la pac
oui vous allez élaboré d'ici l'été un
plan stratégique national qui donnera
les grandes orientations de la france
alors il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes chez
les agriculteurs
l'essai chez les céréaliers notamment
qui s'inquiète des conditions dans
lesquelles ils pourront obtenir des
aides les échos régime c'est une
nouvelle forme d' aides européennes
conditionnée à de meilleures pratiques
environnementales alors deux questions
comment vous pouvez les rassurer d'une
part et sur les 63 milliards de la pac
combien seront conditionnées à des
pratiques écologiques alors je vais
commencer par votre deuxième question et
je reviendrai sur la première parce que
ça me paraît extrêmement important au
moment même où vous savez souvent on dit
est ce que les transitions agro
écologiques elles sont elles sont
véritablement mis en place certains de
nos concitoyens se disant mais il
faudrait que ça aille toujours plus vite
etc
de quoi parle-t-on on parle d'une
politique agricole commune qui a jusqu'à
présent conditionner les les paiements
directs que nous faisons aux
agriculteurs il a conditionné ces
paiements directs avec des pratiques
environnementales à hauteur de 30 % des
paiements
ça c'est la pac actuelle dans la
nouvelle pac
ces conditionnalités qui portait sur 30
% des paiements
elle porte désormais sur 100% des
paiements et en plus de cela on rajoute
un nouveau dispositif qui s'appelle
l'écho régime qui vient donc en plus de
cela dira pour 25% a priori des
pratiques vous devrez des paiements vous
devrez avoir encore de nouvelles
pratiques
imaginez dans quel secteur aujourd'hui
un tel effort de transition
environnementale est réalisé je suis pas
sûr qu'il y en ait beaucoup d'autres que
l'agriculture et je le dis parce que
quand je l'entends souvent celles et
ceux et parfois avec des finalités
politiques critiquer nos agriculteurs
nos monde notre monde de l'élevage ou
autres en disant mais l'écologie dans
l'agriculture et doit être encore plus
profonde moi je fais partie de ceux qui
n'ont jamais opposé agriculture écologie
et on qui ont toujours mis en avant que
ces transitions agro écologiques elles
étaient elles étaient là et cette
nouvelle politique agricole commune en
est une nouvelle preuve
mais je doute qu'on soit bien clair le
chiffre que vous me donnez ce matin ses
25 alors je dis 25% parce que ce chiffre
il ne dépend pas de moi il finit
dépendre la commission européenne il y
avait des divergences je crois entre le
parlement et les 30%
sur ce qu'ils voulaient 20 exactement ça
n'a pas encore été tranchée pourquoi je
dis 25% parce que vous l'avez très bien
résumé le conseil pardon d'être
technique mais nos conseils européens
c'est-à-dire les ministres ont décidé
20% le parlement a voulu 30% dans le
cadre de ce qu'on appelle le trilogue
c'est à dire la fin de la négociation
entre la commission les ministres et
parlement probablement puisqu'on est
entre 20 et 30 % ça pourrait être 25 ans
tel que ce sera décidé normalement d'ici
la fin du mois d'avril début du mois de
mai et jeudi 25 % parce que dans toutes
les évaluations qu'on fait avec la
profession nous prend ce chiffre là mais
il n'est pas encore actée et merci de
m'avoir reprises sur ce point le
deuxième élément c'est que cet écho au
régime
il doit accompagner des agriculteurs et
c'est très important à mes yeux il ne
doit pas exclure il doit inclure et il
ya eu des chiffres qui ont été diffusées
qui ne sont pas de vrais chiffres
certains par exemple vous l'avez
peut-être entendu on disait mais seul un
agriculteur sur quatre aura accès
c'était qu'au régime c'est faux au
moment où je vous parle
alors que la consultation est en cours 1
alors que les discussions sont toujours
en cours avec le monde agricole dans les
premières évaluations et tout cela va
encore évoluer
on est déjà à au moins sept agriculteurs
sur dix qui ont accès à cet écho au
régime dont vous voyez la différence
laisse errer la science aaas inquiète
énormément est ce que vous pouvez les
rations je vous rassure il s'inquiète
énormément parce que ils ont vu que
qu'il y avait des chiffres qui
circulaient en disant que seul un sur
quatre d'entre eux auraient accès à cet
éco régime mais ce que je vous dis c'est
que avant même d'avoir fini les
discussions qui sont pleinement cours
pour améliorer le dispositif pour faire
en sorte encore une fois qu'ils
l'accompagnent qu'il inclut on est déjà
à sept sur dix nous voyez on passe de 1
sur 4 à 7 sur 10 alors même qu'on va
continuer à faire évoluer le système
pourquoi parce que moi je veux un
système qui accompagne la transition
agro écologiques
elle s'accompagne donc il s'agit pas de
dire à certains on vous met de côté vous
bénéficiez pas du dispositif
il s'agit au contraire de dire au plus
grand nombre vous rentrez dans le
dispositif pour qu'on puisse vous
accompagnez dont je veux quelque chose
qui soit inclusif
pourquoi il ya eu des chiffres qui sont
qui ont été véhiculées ou qui sont
transmis parce que moi j'ai une méthode
c'est la vraie concertation et c'est à
dire que je travaille à livre ouvert
avec les professions je trouve que c'est
comme ça qu'on avance
quand vous travaillez à livre ouvert ça
veut dire que vous mettez plein de
chiffres sur la table et parfois
quelqu'un on prend un ca se diffuse
alors que ce n'est pas du tout la
globalité ou quoi pour vous le but c'est
quoi c'est de la basse politique
mais ces deux là et c'est bien normal
non bleuets ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre dans la politique agricole
commune c'est qu'on avait un défi très
fort pour nous france c'était de faire
en sorte que le budget de la politique
agricole commune et soit le plus
importante possible alors que la
commission européenne l'avait
significativement réduit et c'est une
victoire de la france singulièrement du
président de la république d'avoir
réussi à véritablement retourner la
table et faire en sorte qu'on ait un
budget à la hauteur de notre ambition
c'est le budget que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure c'est à peu près de 9 milliards
et demi d'euros par an pour
l'agriculture française et ce budget là
maintenant on doit le répartir entre les
filières sait pas que c'est pas une
négociation budgétaire sur le montant on
a déjà fait mais on a eu une bonne
négociation c'est de le répartir entre
toutes les filières alors chaque filière
fait entendre sa voix et c'est bien
normal
et moi je le fais avec méthode c'était
consultation concertation discussions à
livre ouvert donc ici ou là vous pouvez
avoir des chiffres qui circulent mais
qui à qui on peut faire dire beaucoup de
choses et confère ce que je viens de
vous dire sur l'éco régime mais je crois
que c'est comme ça qu'on avance et je
garderai cette cette méthode assure la
politique agricole commune parmi les
parmi tous les secteurs qui risquent
d'être touchés par les réformes
notamment celle des aides couplées alors
il ya les éleveurs qui s'interroge
énormément sur une perte de chiffre de
chiffre d'affaires ce chiffre d'affaires
là aussi ce que vous pouvez dés rassurer
ou est ce qu'il faudra pour une
catégorie des éleveurs et bien
s'attendre à des à des réformes
profondes sur le
là aussi je tiens leur dire parce qu'il
ya eu beaucoup de de remonter il ya des
craintes que on est encore dans le cadre
de la discussion de la concertation et
qu'on travaille avec l'ensemble des
filières et notamment la filière de
l'élevage
qu'est-ce qui a aujourd'hui il ya un
sujet qui est devant nous c'est de se
dire ces aides couplées qu'ils sont des
êtres très importante très importante
ces êtres couple et est ce que leur
mécanisme est le plus approprié pour
l'éleveur et pour la création de valeur
et c'est cette réflexion là qu'on mène
je veux pas rentrer dans les détails qui
sont très techniques mais c'est cette
réflexion là qu'on mène pour dire est ce
que la méthode de calcul de ces aides
couplées ne doit pas évolué permettant
aux éleveurs de gagner plus d'autonomie
dans la gestion de leur cheptel et en
même temps incitant à faire encore plus
de création de valeur au sein des
filières qui est la marque france la
marque france c'est la qualité et c'est
cette réflexion qu'on mène en ce moment
moi je suis convaincu qu'il faut faire
se bouger là je pense que c'est très
important
évidemment là aussi on le fait dans la
consultation de la concertation on va
parler d'un autre client parler du
rapport papa oui rapport de serge papin
l'ancien pdg de système u qui a rendu
ses conclusions fait des propositions
alors vous avez assuré vouloir bouger
les lignes pour mettre fin je cite au
jeu de dupes des négociations
commerciales annuelles
c'est l'une des propositions du rapport
papin comment comptez vous vous y
prendre justement pour reprendre ses
propositions est ce qu'une nouvelle loi
va arriver ce que vous comment vous
allez passer et surtout est-ce que vous
pouvez là aussi race a rassuré parce que
la loi et galim de 2018 on sent bien
qu'elle n'a pas été au bout des choses
et que le rapport papin est très attendu
vous avez bien résumé la chose
la loi est gagnée mais elle était
nécessaire elle a fait des avancées mais
elle n'est pas allée au bout des choses
c'est exactement ça et donc avec serge
papin que j'ai missionné il ya
maintenant six mois avec qui on a
évidemment travailler tous les jours
faisant depuis ces six derniers mois
il permet ce rapport je le crois de
combler les lacunes de la loi et galim
et de faire les avancées qui sont
aujourd'hui nécessaires pour répondre à
votre question probablement ses
nécessitera
de modifier la loi donc probablement il
nous faudra avoir un texte de loi qui si
on veut que ce soit efficace pour les
prochaines négociations commerciales
doit débuter ce son passage dans les
chambres avant l'été ou d'ici l'été dans
un parlementaire qui est déjà très serré
mans donc dans un délire cdc en fait des
aménagements qui sont qui sont très
courts c'est-à-dire un texte de loi ne
serait pas du tout un texte de loi très
long c'est ces quelques dispositions
mais qui permet de finaliser la chose
pour être très schématique mais pour
qu'on soit classé adoption définitive
avant la fin de l'été pendant ces
moments si on veut que les que les
mesure soit efficace il faut qu'elle
soit entrée en vigueur avant le mois
d'octobre qui le début des négociations
commerciales sagesse a laissé très peu
de temps ça laisse à venir mais conseil
des ministres a vite sauf si c'est pas
un projet de loi mais si c'est une
proposition on a un gros travail avec
les parlementaires ont fait on mène
toutes ces discussions en ce moment avec
eux et pour vraiment servir vous y
travaillez déjà on ne travaille déjà
bien entendu et j'y et ce sur quoi il
faut vraiment que que que ceux qui nous
regardent comprennent c'est pourquoi je
dis que c'est un jeu de dupes
parce que aujourd'hui dans une relation
agroalimentaire vous avez en fait 3
personnes vous avez l'éleveur
l'industriel qui transforme le produit
de l'éleveur et la grande distribution
est aujourd'hui notre principal sujet de
souveraineté et vous avez toujours vieux
moi je crois dans notre souveraineté
agroalimentaire notre principal sujet de
souveraineté c'est que l'éleveur où
l'agriculteur n'a pas la rémunération de
la qualité de son produit à la juste
valeur
or notre adn c'est la qualité notre
singularité c'est la qualité et si on
l'a rémy n'a pas ça marchera et pourquoi
c'est un jeu de dupes parce que
l'éleveur il dit à la grande
distribution augmenter mon prix d'achat
puisque moi je vous donne du produit de
qualité et la grande distribution a dit
ben j'ai proposé un industriel
d'augmenter votre prix mais j'ai eu un
doute
j'étais pas sûr que l'industriel allez
vous rétrocéder l'augmentation de prix
jamais effectuée et les verts sur ton
vers l'industriel et l'industrie et lui
dit bah figurez-vous que moi j'ai
demandé à la cour
distribuer sur le dos mais l'agriculteur
sinon disent que ce que fait ce qu'on
voudrait faire avec monsieur papa voilà
c'est à dire dans tous ces contrats là
on sait ce qu'on appelle de la
contractualisation faire un contrat avec
les trois personnes et non pas des bouts
de contrat de faire de la transparence
s'est passé de la guerre des prix à la
transparence des marches de faire de la
pluriannualité et d'aller même sur le
fait que si dans la première partie du
contrat entre l'éleveur et l'industriel
le prix qui a été négocié entre eux
pouvaient être fixées figé pour qu'il ne
puisse être renégocié ensuite entre
l'industriel et la grande distribution
à ce moment là on arriverait
définitivement mais jamais en fait ce
qu'on a du mal à percevoir c'est déjà la
loi et galim en fait visait à obtenir
des prix plus justes
là le rapport papin trouver peut-être
d'autres solutions mais qu'est ce qui va
faire que l'on va réussir avec le
rapport pas parce qu'on n'a pas réussi
avec la légalité je suis désolé c'est là
aussi très technique qui est de bon
matin j'aurais pas permis aux auditeurs
mais la loi est légal iml a fait ce
qu'on appelle la marche en avant dans
cette relation à trois dans cette
relation improbable aloi galy maladie
quand vous êtes un éleveur l'industrie
et la grande distribution qu'en
l'éleveur négocier avec l'industriel
c'est la première étape et l'industriel
ne pas les négocier avec la grande
distribution que si c'est ça la marche
en avant l industriel à d'abord négocié
avec l'éleveur mais ce que n'a pas fait
la loi et galim c'est de dire cette
marche en avant l' dans la loi et galim
c'est une méthode mais ce que n'a pas
fait la loi et denim ses dires ce qui a
été négocié
d'abord entre l'industriel et l'éleveur
il faut que ça soit figé par la loi
galim dit c'est d'abord l'industriel et
l'éleveur et après avec la grande
distribution
mais la loi est gagnée mais ne dit pas
c'est l'industriel avec l'éleveur une
fois que c'est négocier cette partie là
n'est plus négociable
ensuite entre l'industriel à la grande
distribution et c'est ça qui manque
c'est comment vous rendre figé en fait
ce qui a d'abord été négocié dans cette
marche en avant et c'est ça qu'on
propose avec serge papa alors ça envoie
énormément de s'emporter normalement de
considérations juridiques de travail
technique travaux
avec nos parlementaires mais jusqu'à la
fin de la marche un même travail avec
les parlementaires de la majorité
présidentielle où c'est un travail trans
partisan alors il ya eu une travaille
beaucoup avec les évidemment les
parlementaires de la majorité mais j'ai
eu un travail qui a été fait également
avec je ne sais si c'est une commission
d enquête ou d'un rapport d'évaluation
avec thierry benoit le député avec
grégory besson moreau impliquant
d'autres députés
je crois qu'il ya une adhésion assez
forte sur ce sujet qui en portent
beaucoup beaucoup il ya la marche vous
avez gorille besson moreau qui travaille
beaucoup pour moi c'est pas le seul mais
oui bien il a beaucoup travaillé avec
mon obsession va parler d'un autre sujet
la grippe aviaire est ce qu'aujourd'hui
encore des foyers de grippe aviaire en
france non on en a plus on a plus de
foyers dans les élevages depuis le 26
mars
et on n'a pas observé de cas dans la
faune sauvage depuis le 23 mars c'est
une très bonne nouvelle
c'est une très bonne nouvelle à
plusieurs titres d'abord parce que cet
épisode de ding fring savières a été
absolument terrible et je dois dire que
les décisions courageuses qu'on a prises
en mois de décembre avec la profession
qui à l'époque était parfois posé poser
question en disant mais pourquoi vous
allez aussi fort tout de suite se sont
avérées payantes
on a quand même dû abattre trois
millions et demi de volaille mais quand
vous regardez ce chiffre par rapport aux
précédents épisodes
quand vous regardez la dangerosité du
virus pour nous voilà il cette année
ding fring sa rivière par rapport à sa
dangerosité
les fois précédentes cette année c'était
beaucoup plus virulent c'est ça a été
une gestion qui a permis de limiter très
fortement les exerce à limiter monsieur
ministre mais est-ce que ça pose pas
encore des questions sur l'avenir sur le
développement de l'élevage intensif sur
la vaccination ce qui a pas des leçons à
tirer
alors il ya beaucoup de leçons on fait
d'abord on a trois étapes dans cette
gestion d'abord la sainte de de
l'extinction d'un incendie depuis le 26
mars donc on a plus de cas dans les
élevages
la deuxième phase c'est l'indemnisation
on a mis en place tout un mécanisme
d'indemnisation parce que nos éleveurs
aussi ont été incroyablement durement
touchés et donc nous sommes à leurs
côtés avec la profession une nouvelle
fois mais on a mis des milk en place des
mécanismes d'indemnisation très rapides
beaucoup plus rapide de 2 de ceux dont
on avait l'habitude et la troisième
phase c'est exactement ce que vous allez
dire c'est né d'hier c'est l'évaluation
et quelles conséquences on peut en tirer
c'est pas sur moi je crois pas je fais
pas partie de ceux qui considèrent qu'
il faut poser les modes d'élevage
vous avez en gros des élevages à ciel
ouvert et des neiges qui ne sont pas à
ciel ouvert je pense que ce n'est pas ça
le sujet je pense que le sujet c'est
quand on voit le virus d'influenza
aviaire arrivé et on le voit pas ce
qu'ils arrivent des pays nordiques
quand on le voit arriver dans quelle
mesure on a la capacité de réagir de
réagir et de protéger nos volailles ce
virus il n'est pas en france ce virus il
est transporté par des oiseaux
migrateurs qui viennent en contact
d'autres volailles soudain un exemple
très précis dans les derniers plans il y
avait toujours des équipes d exemption d
exception
d'un nombre assez conséquent de volaille
qu'on pouvait laisser à l'extérieur
or on sait bien aujourd'hui que le
l'oiseau sauvage qui est en contact avec
ces animaux et d'extérieur c'est par
exemple comme ça que le virus pouvait
ensuite se transmettre dans un premier
élevage ou s'épandre c'est c'est une
discussion qu'on a avec la profession
aujourd'hui en disant est ce que dans
les conclusions ne doit pas limiter
fortement au moment où le virus arrive
le nombre d'oiseaux à l'extérieur mais
ça ne veut pas dire je le voudrais dire
une sorte de confinement en fait pour
les volailles sur les coordinations
qu'on appelle des claustration d'animaux
mais ça ne veut pas dire arrêtez les
élevages à ciel ouvert dont moi je crois
mais de se dire comment quand le virus
arrive voyant capable de protéger
exactement on est en capacité de
protéger ces élevages ou autre exemple
on voit bien que ce virus il est aussi
beaucoup transmis dans les mouvements
qu'on peut avoir entre différentes
structures sur les roues d'un camion sur
les habits des personnes qui travaillent
et sait comment ces mesures de
protection sont faites et donc là on a
mis en place un travail depuis
maintenant de longues semaines avec
toute la profession pour faire en sorte
que ce que mon prédécesseur stéphane le
foll avait fait en 2017 on puisse le
réactualiser à l'aune de l'épisode qu'on
a vécu avec là aussi des mesures
courageuses qu'on devra prendre pour se
dire il faut qu'on soit encore plus près
beaucoup a déjà été fait mais force est
de constater que là aussi c'est pas
suffisant
donc comment on va une étape
supplémentaire pour protéger nos cépages
bien deux questions politiques pour
terminer vous faites partie des
fondateurs dans marche vous êtes l'un
des pionniers julien de normandie le
voeu partie en tout cas le mouvement qui
a fêté ses cinq ans est ce que le l'un
des bilans de ce mouvement c'est pas que
vous souffrez toujours d'un manque
criant d'implantation locale vous
n'arrivez pas à vous implanter dans les
territoires avec clairement c'est l'un
des principaux défis auxquels on n'a pas
encore su répondre
preuve en est les résultats aux
élections municipales
à ce titre les prochaines élections
j'ai un mental et régionales sont
difficiles aussi
oui mais ce service et une implantation
locale c'est quelque chose qui est pour
un mouvement politique toujours l'enjeu
le plus compliqué parce qu'une
implantation locale
ça se fait pas du jour au lendemain du
temps ça nécessite d'avoir d'abord des
conseillers municipaux d'avoir des
conseillers généraux des conseillers
régionaux et donc oui très clairement
dans les défis parce que moi je me
tourne vers l'avant et plutôt que de me
retourner derrière mais dans les défis
pour l'inclusion de ce mouvement partout
sur le territoire il y a effectivement
cette question de la structuration
territoire y est vous avez raison les
doigts philippe il peut être un atout ou
est ce qu'il faut est aussi un
inconvénient comment vous le percevez ou
danseurs moi je vais me fâcher
évidemment beaucoup travaillé avec lui
et j'ai été un de ses ministres pendant
trois ans je pense que edouard philippe
il a incarné ce dépassement qui étaient
là dès end en marche en 2017 lorsqu'il
nous a rejoint et je pense qu'il est
d'une il a été d'une loyauté auprès du
président de la république par le passé
je suis sûr qu'il ait dû noyauté sur le
présent et qui vit dans les loyal et
libre libre moi j'ai alors je le dis
vraiment avec beaucoup de sérénité je
pense qu'il n'y a aucun sujet il a été
un un premier ministre avec lequel j'ai
eu beaucoup de plaisir à travailler je
pense qu'ils qu'il est il est
aujourd'hui aux côtés de la majorité aux
côtés du néo zélandais elle prend un
exemple il s'est adressé d'ailleurs il
ya quelques jours au moment des cinq ans
dans marche
avant-hier et là il s'est adressé
d'ailleurs aux membres de deux aux
adhérents dans marche ce qui prouve bien
sa proximité très forte avec des partis
l'udc il est encarté nulle part
d'ailleurs non ils disaient oui non
c'est mais c'est plus fin que que ça il
dit qu' il faut l'engagement politique
est très important et que l'engagement
partisan les
il est tout autant mais ça veut dire que
en fait c'est très important de pouvoir
faire vivre ces mouvements politiques
ces partis politiques je crois que c'est
vrai et je salue d'ailleurs tout ce quel
que soit le bord politique qu'ils
s'engagent je crois que maintenant il ya
besoin de l'engager lit pendant selon
les informations d'europe 1 ce matin
emmanuel macron doit annoncer cet après
midi la suppression de l'ena est ce que
vous me confirmer certains puisqu'il
n'est pas d'informations dessus ce
serait une bonne chose pour vous pour
résoudre cette défiance entre les
français et leurs élus ça se résume pas
à cette proposition là mais le président
la république a toujours eu un message
et une vision très claire sur ce sujet
souvenez vous de sa conférence de presse
à l'issue des 2 au mois d'avril 2018
2019 pardon j'ai un doute où il avait
clairement indiqué la la réforme
nécessaire d'un certain nombre sujet de
formation de nos élites public samedi 19
à l'issue du grand débat en 2019 pour
faire en sorte que cette proximité cette
prise avec les territoires soit la plus
forte possible et je crois que tout ça
évidemment va dans ce sens et ce sera le
mot de la fin merci on entend dire merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous merci
julien lécuyer la une de la voix du nord
sport eco vie de l'adaptation permanente
c'est à la une de votre journal ce matin
merci beaucoup
[Musique]